the gyro can experience remember when
soccer Robbie used to fight yeah what's
neat its knees were like mummified yeah
yeah they were covered halfway up his
thigh all the way down his calf he's to
have the most crazy knee wraps ever I
mean and Sakuraba was a leglock
specialist who he probably mangled his
knees and training you know and all the
fights and all the training I heard
smokes and drinks before smokes and
drinks before practice he didn't give a
[ __ ] cigarettes do you remember when he
fought Conan Silveira and they made yet
again he fought twice in the same day
they fought they fought John McCarthy
stopped the fight
Conan hit him with an uppercut and
Sakuraba Trump chopping down grabbed
ahold of an angle was fighting for a
takedown and John and he's got the fight
because he thought he thought talk
around went out so there in Japan
everybody goes crazy alright they this
was the same year this is the same fight
where Frank Shamrock submitted Kevin
Jackson remember oh yeah the armor that
dawn armbar with shoes on the fastest
are barred history of lumbars was it I
don't know it looks like one of them as
soon as he took him down arm boom arm
bar yeah so he fights again and yeah
mitts cone adding another lock room what
then they fought again like one fight
later and so when they fight again
Sakuraba gets him in an armbar and makes
him tap one like what a Brazilian
jiu-jitsu blackbelt tapped like no one
thought that Conan would tap like this
is crazy
Sakuraba was so special oh my god this
generation that didn't get to watch him
fight have to go back and look at those
fights oh they have to go back there was
something so special about him yeah I
don't know what it was and look I love
the Gracie's and he was beating the
Gracie's and I couldn't help but like
him do you call him the Gracie hunter
remember yeah nobody broke his arm yes
yes the Kimura yep Penza was winning
that fight yeah just came down to the
last little exchange well in that
scramble
Enzo's arm just look at that oh my god
oh my God look at that yeah it's [ __ ]
nasty hens will beat him after in
metamoris and grappling match oh that's
right and how like beat him in the MMA
how the Gracie well that's right that
was very gutsy of Holly that's right so
you know I'm gonna go fight this greasy
hunter you know who dismantled him who
mayhem Miller really mayhem Miller was
fine he was in his prime
when mayhem Miller went over and fought
in he fought in Pride when he was in his
prime hmm and when he was really a
contender and he systematically broke
soccer alba down beat the [ __ ] out of
and submitted him he's a very tough guy
he was [ __ ] a good man for a while
look at him they're throwing a peace
sign up it was all those crazy guy
there's always crazy guy and then you
know like legit problems after that I
imagine as and then after the Bisping
fight you know then he had even more
legit problems but in that fight man he
was on point
he beat the [ __ ] out of Sakuraba the
scariest loss though that Sakuraba ever
had well there's three scary losses the
two two Vandelay they're both terrifying
he got really [ __ ] up by Mandalay but
then Melvin Manhoef Melvin Manhoef beat
the [ __ ] out of him with soccer kicks on
the ground and all that crazy [ __ ] back
when Melvin was Melvin just Melvin
remember when that guy was built like oh
my goodness like [ __ ] like a
superhero it didn't look like a real
person I've seen him fight live I mean
the guy's a savage whoo he's fast but he
knocked out Mark Hunt with one punch did
you know oh yes he was a hundred and
eighty five pounds you know I got mark
hunt with one this boxing fight though
right was it no was mm mm II know look
at Melvin Jesus Christ he was gladiators
shorts on those uh those the gladiator
frill shorts he formed him up that's not
a soccer Robert oh no that's someone
else he's fighting the greatest fight
one of the greatest the the greatest
comeback fight I've ever seen in my life
was k1 hero's Sakuraba he's getting beat
up by this Luther winning guy I don't
even know the guys name and weren't
we're in Japan we're watching some main
event put this ahead to the actual fight
here but back it up a little back it up
back it up back it's a real quick fight
man it happens in life no no go like
where the K is seize it no see where it
says two point three point seven X 3
point 7 K with a thumb up the first
thumb up go to that part right there BAM
right there click there click there yeah
but well it's right before it gets
fighting they're right about the his dog
collar on you bring him out on a leash
Asst coach yeah had a talk Colorado he
was at Mike's gym legged yeah
scoot up right there good right there
it's good when you see them so they're
there fighting off and so mark hunt
charges at them and when Mark Hart
charges at them
Melvin just catches him while he's
coming in so they exchanged a little bit
here on the feet just a little bit of
moving around mark on so much bigger
than him man
mark comp might be a hundred pounds
bigger than him no [ __ ] he easily
could be 290 easily and a tank look at
this boo one shot I mean come on son who
the [ __ ] narcs knocks out mark hunt with
one punch it's crazy that's crazy he was
so [ __ ] fast man so [ __ ] fast
there's a there's a key when heroes
fight Sakuraba fights like a Lithuanian
guy an unknown guy and this guy is
beating the hell out of Sakuraba oh god
I fight yeah he is beating I'm like stop
here stop this fight right here he's
between the ropes and doing guys I work
at God and the Japanese people just
believe in him so much they know he's
gonna make it out of there and he comes
up comes back to life we're like what
and then the arm versus Lithuanian guy
and then they throw up the confetti and
everybody these people just believe this
unlike stop this fight
I mean I'm live here I'm in the stance I
mean I gotta fight I just punch the Vice
everything oh my can stop the fight no
no no not gonna stop the fight no I just
have to fight crazy wait a second
although they want to bring him back in
the ring yep ah he's out of bounds okay
yeah he's punched him while the reports
come before even said good go hammer
fist at him this is one of the greatest
comebacks I've ever seen in my life yeah
it makes you think there's no way soccer
I was gonna survive here
there's no way and he keeps moving and
this guy keeps punching him yeah this is
crazy and he's standing up to he was no
tomorrow and he's hammer in the back of
his head Sakuraba was just he had no
quit in him you know like none and
sometimes that was horrible to watch
because he would wind up getting beat up
hmm look at his leg like look at that
[ __ ] right leg how much is taped up
it's crazy
this guy's holding the fence too
yep yeah so I actually gets him down
scoot up a little bit there Jeremy yeah
this is a bTW this is a beating and the
leading get some upstanding - yeah he
blues what hey exhaust he got too tired
here and eventually soccer out catch so
look at these uppercuts the audience is
going one sorry was berserk that crowd
was losing it at this point
yeah they believe in him so much when he
lost the first time he was like look I'm
happy now that the weight is off my
shoulders you know the Japanese people
now they know I can lose and like get
too much pressure on him they always
expect them to win
scoot ahead oh there it is you see mount
some credit they said that's how you
finish Conan - same you say move yeah
incredible
[Applause]